bien alors maintenant on va passer à la
dernière rubrique de l'émission dernier
jeu de l'émission je pense et en
contrebas
noah n'a pas vraiment eu la bien
vraiment ça ressemble à une bonne
éducation parce que je pense des suites
deux fois puis après tu ne bouges plus
tabou j'ai un petit peu les yeux mais
bon voilà le principe ça s'appelle
personne ne me connaissait principe
c'est le jeu de la vérité
donc on est un soir avec des amis on a
un peu bu et on décide de se dire la
vérité toute la vérité d'accord alors je
veux bien commencé mais chacun peut
poser des questions aux autres est ce
qu'on peut baisser serge la lumière s'il
te plait je le jeu de la vérité je
connais oui ça me rappelle les lacs
souvenirs tantôt se dit la vérité et
samedi veilles des souvenirs de colo
quand on arrête de typo kruth la vérité
toute la vérité toute nue
oui oui il était à l'époque d'écolo
c'était l'occasion dirait alors être que
tu m'aimes voilà est-ce que finalement
on peut dire en conclusion vous regarde
pas quelle est ta carrière tu as vit
depuis trente ans que tu n'as pas voulu
rentrer dans le rang tu as toujours
voulu rester marginal et est ce que t'as
pas le sentiment quand même qu'à cause
de ça tu as un peu raté ta vie dit tout
ouais j'ai vachement raté mon canton
vote mais comme une encore une fois ce
n'était pas le plus important
un nom c'est moi mon ambition dans la
vie c'était de me marrer grosso merdo
j'y suis à peu près arrivé à éviter les
écueils et tout prix l'empêcher
franchement avancer la vérité là ah oui
franchement francis est ce que
vous ne regrettez pas finalement
cinquantaine comme ça ne pas avoir
essayé les mecs n'ont elles finissent à
elle est finie bon j'ai maintenant un
rôle d'anne tu peux aussi posé toit des
questions aux gens qui sont là c'est le
principe j'ai pas à parler tout le temps
j'ai une question à poser à crise il
passé comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
je trouve que c'est une personne
attachante et c'est vrai que quand on
sait qu'on va le rencontrer on se
documente un peu et c'est vrai que tu as
dit beaucoup beaucoup de conneries pour
moi la plus grosse c'est de ne pas
accepter l'homosexualité de la montrer
du doigt comme étant une tare physique
tu va à l'encontre de l'évolution du
monde si les choses sont comme ça qu'ils
passent les que les couples homos passe
à la mairie ou pas ça tu n'arrêtera pas
la marche du temps est ce que tu te
rends compte malgré ta sincérité que tu
dis parfois des conneries énorme mais ce
n'était pas un petit peu prisonnière de
ton personnage médiatisé optionnels sont
perspective qui sans doute autant de
conneries que toi certainement mais moi
je sais mon boulot à la différence de
toi c'est que et c'est peut-être là où
je suis idiote
peut-être que je me trompe mais c'est
vrai que moi j'ai un certain nombre
certitude c'est à dire que le bo n'est
pas égal ou l'est pour moi il ya un bien
il ya un mal
je sais ce que c'est alors je peux me
tromper mais j'essaie de certitudes là
que ça crée bien l'âme une question vous
avez envie de poser à quelqu'un ici est
très très sincère parce que cette
heure-là il est tellement tard que tout
le monde dit la vérité
un francis est ce que ces écoutes un peu
à la radio faire la réponse oui mais
malheureusement que tu n'as pas compris
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
physiquement je t'ai entendu mais
physiquement j ai jamais mais pas du
tout
voilà mais oui bien sûr oui la gestion
en france plus encore justement dans
l'une des émissions vous étiez présent
l'autre jour je vous ai vu avec votre
petit fia scaramouche je voudrais savoir
si à force de jouer peut-être des
variétés vous attrapez syndrome belmondo
qui se baladent par son chien
j'espère c'est super sympa on a toujours
l'impression justement quand on a un
chien que ça veut dire qu'on est
efféminé mais c'est bon d'être malade en
vue d'assurer ses dires c'est un chien
pour moi c'est ainsi un être humain je
veux dire c'est incroyable il ya 350
mots vraiment je les ai vérifiés il est
là non ils voient la valeur
non mais c'est vrai qu'il comprenne
vraiment on dit des mots il est complet
tout à fait juste une question
c'est une question très piège vous le
jurer de répondre vraiment très bien non
la norges c'est qui paye c'est très sain
en fonction de tout ce qui a été dit un
homme et un homme qui vivent ensemble
qui s'aiment humainement moralement
sexuellement
ils se font du bien ou du mal je ne sais
pas moi je pense que deux hommes qui
s'aiment et deux femmes qui s'aiment
moralement physiquement se font du bien
ouais